excellent avery is going to post in some
leftovers to get you started
okay hello everyone well after a one
week
gap for the holiday back again for
science and technology q
a for kids and others
and so i think we had a few questions
left over
from last time
um
uh let's see so there's a question from
brian here
how does one imagine a color that one
has never seen before
that is an interesting question always
discussed by
uh philosophers and so on how do you
imagine something
that you haven't seen i think the only
way that one
imagines things one hasn't seen is by
fitting them into a context of things
one has seen
so you know we get a little bit more of
an understanding of how
things like brains work from what's gone
on with artificial neural nets
in ai artificial intelligence systems
so in the last probably nearly ten years
now
there's been a lot of progress in
making uh computer systems that
learn from examples that where you give
it
a bunch of pictures of cats a bunch of
pictures of dogs and you tell it in each
case this is a cat this is a dog
and then you show it a new picture and
it has learnt
to uh distinguish a cat from a dog
and so the question uh and if you look
so the question is
and the way it learns is it's tweaking a
bunch of numbers
millions of numbers that represent how
it's going to
uh weight the treatment how it's going
to weight and combine and so on
all the different uh pixel values that
it sees in the image
but so the question is does it learn
the concept of a cat or the concept of a
dog
or is it just saying with this
particular
way of combining pixels i can deduce as
a cat or a dog
it's not so obvious that it learns the
the concept
but that would be i think the best place
to look to understand
is there a way to learn about
some new color that you have never seen
that um uh in other words you can
you say this new color that i
can't see because maybe i'm color blind
or maybe
it's outside the visible range of colors
how does that what is it like can i
imagine what it's like
well can i imagine it well i think the
way you have to imagine it
is by fitting it into a context of other
things that you know about
let me give an analogy let's say the
word uh
uh i don't know uh
the word splubble okay so i just made
that word up
i don't know you know splobble
on its own we don't know what the word
squabble bubbles
what did i even say squabble no that's a
real word
spo means but as soon as we start
hearing spubble
in a sentence like i took my pet's
bubble for a walk today
then as soon as i start hearing some
context so if i say i took my pet's
bubble for a walk today
you kind of get the idea well maybe a
spubble is a type of animal
um if you say and then you say my pets
bubble
you know ate uh a lot of fish today
that's one thing if you say my pets
bubble eight
uh uh you know um
800 pounds of of food today
you get the idea it's a pretty big
animal whatever it is so
so again with all this sort of context
even though you've never seen a spool
by the time you've heard enough about it
when somebody asks you a question about
it or you you will build up some mental
model
of what a spubble might be um and i
think that's the way that you would
uh you know this original question of
how do you how do you
how do you imagine a color that you've
never seen i think that's
that that's the sort of operational
definition of that
is can you make deductions about this
color can you reason in terms of this
color
um and i think the answer to that is is
to build it up in terms of in terms of
context
now let me give you a practical
application of this that that um
i've been curious about a long time so
so we humans
see uh light that's what our eyes detect
but light is just a type of
electromagnetic radiation
that ranges all the way from radio waves
down to x-rays and gamma rays and things
like that
right outside so so in a rainbow for
example
you're seeing the different frequencies
uh
of of light distinguished from from red
to blue
but actually uh there are more
electromagnetic frequencies beyond the
range that our eyes see
beyond red there's infrared beyond blue
that's ultraviolet
well we can make cameras that can see in
the infrared and in the ultraviolet
in fact your average cell phone camera
can see a little ways into the infrared
and a little ways into the ultraviolet
and it has to have a special filter
to stop it showing you pieces of image
that
are sensitive to infrared and
ultraviolet because then you'd look at
the image and you'd say
that's nothing like what i see with my
eyes because the camera
has detected uh electromagnetic waves
that are
not ones that we can see when you're
going into the infrared
things that uh infrared light
uh infrared radiation it's
when a hot object will produce lots of
infrared
um and uh a colder object will produce
less infrared so for example
if you had an infrared image of me you'd
see you know my skin temperature
is uh well i happen to be a very much in
fahrenheit a very 98.6 degrees
fahrenheit kind of person
so you'd see uh actually the peripheral
skin is not not always the core
temperature but but
you'd see a temperature around 98
degrees fahrenheit
but then like my glasses will be much
colder
and so if you looked at an image of me
in infrared
you'd see this kind of bright area here
and then you'd see this much darker area
for my glasses and so on
um okay so a question is if you
but but if you look at at an image
um in the infrared there's a whole range
of
of of frequencies of infrared just like
there's a whole range of frequencies of
visible light
that we identify as different kinds of
colors so the question is
in the infrared where we don't have
names for the
quotes colors of infrared because our
eyes don't see them
but we can somehow we could try to
represent
infrared light in terms of some kind of
generalized color
and the sort of question is how should
that work and if you were to have an
infrared image
um how how could you color it in a way
that people would understand so for
example you know i'm used to seeing
i don't know a strawberry is red it's
red with respect to visible light
in the infrared i have no idea what uh
what frequencies of of infrared light so
to speak a strawberry produces
but we might represent those in terms of
another set of colors
so this comes up in practice i don't
know if you have a
a car some some cars like um i'm not
even sure
i i don't think my current car does this
but um some cars
have uh they sometimes call it dear
vision or something
uh you know for for watching for for
deer if you're in
if you're in the u.s it's deer running
out on the road if you're in australia
it's kangaroos running out into the road
um but uh for creatures running out of
the road because
the road is cold so it doesn't produce
it's very dark in terms of infrared
um but uh uh you know a warm blooded
animal
is is hot relative to the road and so it
will show up as a sort of bright
thing in infrared so you can get these
these uh
displays that display in your windshield
or something that
will show up with sort of bright dots if
there's something
sort of hot running into the road which
might correspond to an animal
so the question is can you so so those
displays usually just show white on
a black background but the question is
could you show
given that you actually know more about
kind of the the um
uh the the the type of infrared light
the frequency of infrared light
could you actually show more detail and
can you show you know a deer
which might be i don't know a brownish
color invisible light
what is the representation of it in
infrared light and can you tell
you know a a a deer from
what else is the same size i don't know
from a kangaroo for example
obviously you can tell from the shape
but could you tell it and those two are
fairly similar color too
um but fairly similar color invisible
light i don't know if they're a similar
color in infrared light
let's see um
there's a question here from adam
why does blue light prevent you from
sleeping
um well so
the question is when should you be
asleep when should you be awake
your brain your body has to get
some idea of wednesday when's night
how's it going to do that best way to do
that is to use
light levels and and so what will happen
is
you we all have a so-called circadian
rhythm
our our bodies are kind of tuned to work
a bit like clocks
and roughly you know ever on a 24 hour
cycle
for example if you look at the your body
temperature it will vary
on a roughly 24 hour cycle and if you
look at a bunch of other attributes of
your body
including whether you feel tired they'll
tend to vary on a 24-hour cycle
but the question is when is the morning
when is the night how does that 24-hour
cycle get lined up
now you know experiments have been done
where people volunteers
uh live in caves for a long time where
they have no exposure to outside light
and there's always a question of what is
their natural circadian rhythm
do they naturally kind of feel
sleepy every 24 hours or does it
does it um is it different from that
most people
have a natural circadian rhythm that
isn't exactly 24 hours i think it's more
often longer than shorter
um and so if you if you kind of black
everything out
you don't synchronize with the with the
day and night um you'll gradually have
longer and longer and longer days
typically
for most people okay but but
but in any case you've got to decide
given that you have a circadian rhythm
that's roughly 24 hours long
which 24 hours corresponds to you know
when you should be awake when it's
daytime and which corresponds to night
and so what's uh fundamentally that
works using light
but the really strange thing is that
partly it's light that comes into your
eyes there's some evidence
that um the uh pituitary gland which is
right at the center of your brain
um that uh it has some uh
ability to sense light independent of
light shining on your eyes and that's
kind of strange because like
not a lot of light gets through your
skull and things like that um and maybe
this isn't correct
but there is some impression that there
is a
a a way in which you sense overall light
level
that isn't just what you see in your
eyes that goes to your retina to your
optic nerve and so on
but it doesn't really matter for these
purposes the main issue is
that your uh your circadian rhythm is
synchronized
uh by by by seeing somehow
by sensing light um
now the question is which light is more
important
um i i think i i don't know how good the
evidence is for this but it is claimed
that blue light is more significant
in uh that it's kind of like um uh
you know you could imagine in in our
ancient ancestors
that um you know light that's blue was
only available from the sun from
something as hot as the sun the surface
of the sun
like is about 6 000 degrees same as the
surface of a tungsten filament in a
incandescent bulb that produces light
that is looks to us white that contains
a whole lot of blue uh bluish light as
well as some red light
and and the combination of those things
appears to us white
if we have your average fire that uh you
know our ancient ancestors might have uh
might have had going at night uh the the
light it's it's probably much colder
than an incandescent filament on the
surface of the sun
um and so that light tends to be much
more reddish and so
you would expect that uh you know if we
if we had evolved somehow i don't know
whether that evolution would have really
worked
um but if we'd evolved somehow it's like
blue light
you know it's the sun nothing but the
sun
and so it must be daytime reddish like
well that might be a fire going
so it could be night time so that will
be an explanation i don't know whether
it's correct but that's a possible
explanation
for why we would tend to synchronize to
um
uh to to blue light um and we would tend
to be
sort of kept awake and and move our
circadian rhythm
based on blue light more so than red
light
um let's see there's a question here
from paul what advice would you give to
learn
real analysis so real analysis is a
a fancy version of things like calculus
piece of mathematics
i would say my my main meta statement
about these things
is you know use from language use
mathematica
do experiments when you think you've
learned something about
how uh you know the slopes of functions
the way maxima or minimum functions work
the um uh the way that limits work
the way that non-uniformity of limits
works with two different parameters
things like that just try a bunch of
experiments
just try actually making pictures uh try
doing computations with actual functions
that's for me at least that's the way
that i really understand these concepts
and like
for example in this very big case of the
physics project that we've been working
on
um which ends up being a lot of very
abstract mathematics in fact it requires
a vast generalization of the ideas of
real analysis
a generalization that that sort of has
not happened yet in mathematics that we
still have to do
generalization to fractional dimensional
space of the concepts of calculus and so
on
to get an idea about how that works it's
all doing computer experiments
seeing examples of what happens that's
what gives us the clue
that we might need this generalization
of l analysis and so on
but in learning real analysis i think
the key thing is
do computer experiments visualize what's
going on uh
try and try out different kinds of
things that's the way you really get a
good understanding of what's happening
it's a question from sarah here what
happens when you cry in space
well gosh i mean so the two different
things by
what you might mean in space so
uh you know space is
more or less a vacuum there's no
molecules of air or anything like that
um
if you're in space without a spacesuit
you're in very bad shape
because we need the pressure of
of air um pressure of the atmosphere
to to uh to keep us i mean we're we're
used to existing in uh um in
air of a certain pressure so it's not um
uh if we didn't have a spacesuit on
we'd been we'd be in very very terrible
shape because we kind of um
there's pressure that we generate from
inside us
that sort of pushes us outwards and if
that's
usually uh uh that's usually equal to
the pressure that comes from the
atmosphere
around us pressing in on us so kind of
an analogous thing
if you're a fish living deep in the
ocean
like if you're a fish that lives a mile
under the ocean there's a huge
pressure that's produced by that mile of
water on top of you
it's a huge pressure pushing pushing you
in
well a fish like that will have been set
up so that it has
a pressure pushing outwards from inside
the fish
that um uh that keeps it in in in uh
an equilibrium that keeps it there's
pressure from the water pushing in
there's pressure from the insides of the
fish pushing out
uh if you take that fish up to the
surface where the pressure or the
outward pressure is much smaller
the fish will kind of puff up it's
really bad for the fish
um fish probably wouldn't survive being
pulled up from a mile
under the ocean to the surface of that
definitely wouldn't and that's that's
what would happen
to to us if we were in space without a
spacesuit with air inside it
that's that's uh making a sort of
artificial atmosphere
that has pressure in it so that's the
first thing
so uh one of the things that
um uh so so let's assume that you're in
space but you're on a space station
where they're or in a space suit where
there is um
uh artificial atmosphere and there's
enough pressure
to keep you um uh to keep you uh sort of
uh
in the right shape so to speak um then
the the other feature of being in space
like in orbit around the earth
is that you're weightless um instead of
uh on the earth you drop something it
falls under gravity towards the center
of the earth
but when you're in orbit everything is
sort of falling around
the earth and everything is falling at
the same rate
so you will you will
everything seems weightless if you if
you if you
uh you know if you uh
like um if you sneeze instead of the
droplets water
uh kind of dropping to the ground with
gravity as
as they will um or if you throw a ball
instead of it dropping to the ground
with gravity
if you throw a ball when you're
weightless in in orbit around the earth
for example
then uh the ball will just will just
keep going in a straight line it won't
fall down
so so if you were to uh for example
if if you generated like tears in space
they wouldn't um i mean i don't i don't
really know i mean typically
you know if you get uh tears in your
eyes they tend to go down tear ducts
towards your um uh that drain
through you know through the through
towards your nose
and that um all the fluid drains out i
suspect that that wouldn't work in space
i don't know how that works
i don't know um i would guess that that
doesn't work
and actually that's a good question for
for an ask to ask an astronaut is how
that works
out because i think that the drainage of
tears from eyes
depends on gravity to drain them through
tear ducts
so i don't know um and uh that's a good
question
um but so that's that's the um
uh now if if you mean like uh
you know cry out make a sound if you're
in if you're inside a space station and
there's air there
then sound will sound is when when when
you talk
what's happening is that your vocal
tract is vibrating
that's causing uh causing air to be
compressed and expanded compressed and
expanded very quickly maybe uh
a thousand times a second um or
something
and um uh but you know what and that's
what corresponds to the sound
but if you don't have any air there is
no sound
um and you can't you can't there's
nothing
to uh there's nothing in which the sound
can exist the sound consists of
you know you can even feel if you you
know if you push your hand in front of
your mouth when you're talking
you can even feel a little bit the the
the change in pressure where you can't
you can't cut
feel the the the um the uh it's too fast
for you to actually feel but you can
feel that there's some
something going on that that some kind
of uh uh
uh that some uh uh
progressive pressure of of of of um
of air but that's just not present if
you're in the vacuum of space
so you you can't get sounds
um
let's see uh slayer is asking
who is the most underrated scientist
um who comes to mind when you think of a
historical scientist who was unfairly
snubbed
um and you're asking about rosalind
franklin
um in the discovery of the double helix
um gosh that is a good
question uh
you know it's really a complicated story
because here's what often happens
somebody will come up with an idea
they'll describe it
probably they understand the idea in
some sense of understanding their idea
but nobody else understands it and so
then the question is
did they really understand the idea or
not
and often it's really really hard to
tell
and and often there are things that get
discovered
but people just don't know the
significance of them and so then
did the person who noticed that
phenomenon
is that significant or is the real
significance only when the phenomenon
was
when the when the importance of the
phenomenon was understood
so for example uh gosh what's a good
example of this
there's so many i mean there's so many
both in um
in experimental science and in
theoretical science
where people notice things but nobody
really understood the nobody understood
the significance
and people didn't understand the um
uh um people didn't understand
kind of the um uh the people
didn't know whether the people who
originated it even understood the
significance
let me tell you some stories from my own
life so i'm not not picking on other
people
so back in 1979 when i was a teenager
still
um i worked on questions about the early
universe
and one of things i figured out along
with a friend of mine named rocky colb
was um uh who has subsequently become a
very well-known cosmologist
um but anyway so so rocky and i
were studying the very early universe
the first one second
of the existence of the universe and um
uh one of the questions about the early
universe is
uh how did um
how did the early universe manage to get
mixed up enough
that different parts of it are roughly
the same
because usually you expect that
different um
uh male is a little bit complicated but
but usually
it it takes uh kind of uh information to
to travel from one side of the system to
another for it to kind of
become uniform and there wasn't time for
that
in one second after the beginning of the
universe so it's sort of a mystery about
how that worked
and so what we figured out is that
there is a particular okay so so roughly
what
what happens in the in and okay so if
you have a
material like water and you
cool it down enough it'll eventually
turn into ice
it'll make a solid um that process of
going from water to salt
from liquid to solid solid to liquid
that's called the phase transition
and and often there are many materials
where
when you uh if you heat them up
they will show these phase transitions
for example from solid to liquid to gas
whatever else okay so the thing that the
universe is made of or
according to current theories of
particle physics the universe
and it's a slightly complicated thing
it's not an ordinary material made of
atoms and so on
but the universe has a thing called
higgs field um which
uh it contains and one of the things
that should happen
in the very early universe is that in a
sense the higgs field
should go from being kind of like a gas
to being kind of like a solid
it should go from there being a very low
density of higgs field
like like like steam to being a high
density of higgs field like ice
um and that phenomenon should have
happened uh i think about a microsecond
after the beginning of the universe
maybe a little less than that
um depends on the type of higgs field
and a bunch of other details
but any case the um so so this phase
transition should have happened in the
early universe maybe a microsecond
after the very beginning of the universe
okay so rocky and i
figured that out and figured out that
one of the things that happens when um
the characteristics of a solid and a gas
are very different
and the universe the universe expands
and the rate at which the universe
should expand would have been very
different
if the thing had been behaving if the
higgs field and the universe have been
behaving like a gas
versus behaving like a solid so we
figured out there should be this big
big difference in expansion rate of the
universe as a result of that
and more than that we figured out that
well the expansion rate if
if this transition occurred should be
uh it should have very the universe
should have very rapid expansion at
least for a brief period
um and and we also figured out that if
the universe had that kind of rapid
expansion
um then this problem about how different
parts of the universe should communicate
with each other will be solved
okay the problem was that we didn't
we didn't really believe that that would
have happened in the universe because we
in order for that to have been a
significant effect
it would have had to uh okay so so
another thing i should explain
if you have uh water and um
you cool it below zero degrees
centigrade
um you would expect the water is going
to freeze into ice
but it turns out that if you're very
very very careful
and you don't allow and you just have
this water
and you cool it very very very carefully
and there are no
uh there are no imperfections in the
water there are no little pieces of
of dust or anything else nothing nothing
that sort of makes the water not
completely uniform
you can supercool it so that it is below
zero degrees centigrade
but has not yet started forming ice
crystals
hasn't yet started forming solid if you
drop a little if you drop even the
slightest thing
in there immediately below zero degrees
centigrade it will start that will be a
nucleation
site and it will start producing ice and
you'll get this the whole water will
turn into ice
okay but so in order for this effect to
have been important in the early
universe
the early universe would have had to
have supercooled
by a factor of 10 billion it would have
the temperature would have had to go
uh it would have had to not nucleate
this kind of solid higgs field solid
type thing
for 10 billion uh when the temperature
reduced by a factor of 10 billion
relative to where you would expect that
transition to occur
and i said that's just not plausible the
universe
it won't be the case that the universe
will have the characteristics necessary
for that kind of super cooling so we
wrote this
academic paper we put a little footnote
saying well
if this super cooling could happen then
that would be very important for the
for the history of the universe but it
didn't seem plausible supercooling would
happen
okay so other people came along and they
said gosh
this supercooling idea is really
interesting
and we could explain all this stuff
about the universe
if only it's supercooled by that factor
and so they said
let's just assume the universe for some
reason that we don't yet know
supercooled by that factor then we get
to build a whole new version of
cosmology it's called inflationary
cosmology
on the basis of that assumption well
so the question is then you know who
who really figured that out you know
rocky and i
figured out this fact that you could get
the super cooling
it would affect the expansion rate of
the universe what the consequences of
that would be
but we didn't really take that seriously
enough
to say this is really a good model for
for the evolution of the universe and
and really nothing you know it didn't
take something different
the physics wasn't any different it was
just a difference of emphasis
and a difference of context and and i
would say that in that case
you know lots of uh lots of physics and
lots of careers were built on the basis
of this idea of inflationary cosmology
and um it's you know i think rocky in my
footnote
is really just a footnote it's um it's
something where we didn't really
uh understand or really choose to push
the significance of this
whether inflationary cosmology is
correct is a different matter
with our new theory of physics there's a
different approach that i think is
actually much more promising and
probably and maybe we were even correct
that this idea of supercooling just
wouldn't happen the way that
inflationary cosmology says it happens
and
in order to get that super cooling you
have to have all kinds of plugins to
make that work
so that's an example where it's a little
bit of a subtle issue
you know who who is underrated who is
not
um and uh you know i think that kind of
thing happens
over and over again in science i mean
like right now
with our new theory of physics there's a
question
of you know how close did other people
get
to different pieces of this theory and
honestly it's really hard to figure out
really hard to figure out i mean there's
uh there's a person who um
who died a few years ago uh named david
finkelstein
who wrote a book i talked to him a bunch
of times i never understood very well
what he was talking about
but he wrote a book some words in which
seemed to be
kind of pointed in the direction of the
kind of physics we've done but
i don't know whether that's what he
meant um and from talking to him and
asking questions i don't know
that's what he meant um so it's it's
really hard to tell in many cases what
um uh you know and and sometimes
there are there are things where uh you
know some piece of science
is very uh kind of everybody hears about
oh there's this
piece of science and it's it's so
important and
it turns out not to be that important
that can happen
and they're these pieces of science
where people don't hear about it
and it's um uh and it really is
important people didn't really
understand significance now
you know i've done a lot of science in
my life and i think
um i i kind of have my own assessment
of what's important and what's not and
and it's kind of
sometimes frustrating because the things
that people think are important
are things where i think the things that
i've done that were not terribly
important
um and yet other things that i think
were really important
um uh people are like we don't really
understand this and they don't really
pay much attention to it
now it's sort of been interesting to me
that i've been able to kind of test
my ability to figure out what's
important and what's not because
i've been around long enough that i can
kind of see what's happened and
you know i i think i've been doing
really well at figuring out what's
important and what's not
what i'm not doing so well at is
figuring out how long it's going to take
for people to understand this or that
idea
i mean i think it's been it's been
really good without new theory of
physics
you know a lot of those ideas i first
developed
more than 30 years ago now um and uh
the um and 20 years ago i explained them
to a lot of people millions of people
actually
and and really people didn't understand
and it's taken
making uh a bigger sort of tower of
progress to get to the point where
there's things that people can
understand
uh but but you know there are there are
other things that happen in um you know
i've been interested in history of
science and um
they're uh you know when you look at a
big discovery um
there's some uh um
there's often a lot of steps that get
taken along the way
and sometimes the people who you hear
about
as being involved in those steps were
really the important ones and sometimes
they were not
um in the case of the discovery of the
double helix of dna
i don't know that story in enough detail
i i i certainly um
uh know jim watson and i knew francis
crick um
and uh so the you know i can have
opinions based on those individuals
um uh i i don't really know the detailed
story of rosalind franklin
and um the x-ray crystallography that
was done
on um on discovering dna i mean for
people's
interest let me just say a little bit
about about that
process um so dna
it's the molecule that stores the
genetic information in our cells
the actual molecule was known to exist
in the nuclei of cells
for a long time but nobody really knew
how it worked
and nobody knew that it had this idea of
storing information digitally
by using these repeating blocks of
identical collections of atoms and so on
um and so a big issue and certainly
nobody knew
how dna could replicate could make
copies of itself
which is what needs to happen when when
when our cells uh replicate
um and so back in 1953 and just before
1953
the um the thing that um was a big
question was what was the structure of
dna
what was what was it as a uh as a what
shape was the molecule and um so
how do you figure out the shape of a
molecule well there's a kind of a clever
technique
so if you have a crystal a crystal
is a as a solid in which there are atoms
and the atoms are all lined up in a
definite pattern so the sort of defining
characteristic of a crystal
is that it's a repeating there's
sequences of atoms that repeat repeat
repeat repeat
all the time so for example a salt
crystal
you'll have sodium chloride this little
pair of of
of atoms there you just get repeating
repeating repeating
and it's in a cubic grid in the case of
a salt crystal
um and that that's a very simple case
now in the case of dna what was found
was it was possible to make crystals
um in which uh there were that dna was
arranged in a crystal in repeating um in
a lot of repeats of this
of this uh collection of atoms this
molecule that represented dna
and the question was uh what was the
arrangement of atoms
um in this repeating crystal so how do
you figure out the arrangement of atoms
in a crystal
well there's a clever technique that's
called x-ray crystallography
um and it was invented in the 1910s and
1920s i
think um maybe as late as 1930s i'm not
sure
okay here's how it works see if i can
explain this
operationally what happens is you you
shine x-rays onto a crystal and
uh the x-rays are only okay
if you shine light onto a mirror um
it doesn't matter whether it's shining
red light or blue light the light is
always reflected by the mirror
and the the rule for reflection of light
is the angle of incidence the angle
at which the light hits the mirror will
be equal to the angle of reflection
so the light will come in at let's say a
30 degree angle
will bounce out at a 30 degree angle
okay and it does that for all
frequencies of light red light blue
light green light
whatever doesn't matter always the angle
of incidence is equal to the angle of
reflection
okay so um
in the case of x-rays if you shine
x-rays
a beam of x-rays on a crystal it turns
out that's no longer true
that the the x-rays would be reflected
from the crystal
but they are not reflected uh it isn't
the case that the
the x-rays are reflected in any angle so
okay let's assume that we've got just
red light for example
for a mirror we can shine the red light
at a 50 degree angle of 52 degree angle
53 degree angle for every angle we shine
it at
the reflected light will always be
reflected at that same angle
not true for x-rays on a crystal for
x-rays on a crystal
only certain discrete angles
of reflection are allowed other angles
the x-ray
just be absorbed um only it's so it's
only if you if you
if if the x-ray is at a particular angle
then it will get reflected out
the reason for that is a phenomenon
called diffraction which i could explain
but it's a little bit subtle
and it all has to do with the fact that
the wavelength of the x-rays
is comparable to the distance between
well is is actually
is smaller than the distance between the
atom the crystal
let's not explain how the fraction works
but let's just say
that uh with x-rays that only certain
angles
are allowed to be reflected and which
angles are allowed to be reflected
is a uh is a consequence of the
arrangement of atoms in the crystal
but that arrangement is a quite a
complicated mathematical relationship
it's actually what's called the fourier
transform of
the um of the configuration of atoms
basically gives you the diffraction
pattern
that corresponds to the angles at which
the x-rays can be can be reflected so
anyway what was known
for for dna was that the
x-ray diffraction pattern had a
particular form
a bunch of dots that corresponded to the
different angles
at which x-rays could be reflected from
the dna crystal
okay so the question was what shape of
dna crystal
would be the uh the right one to
reproduce the pattern of dots
that would see in the diffraction
pattern now that turns out
a given pattern of dots there can be
many different shapes
that would in principle be consistent
but most of those shapes are not things
that you could make with atoms
not things that would correspond to
ordinary molecules and so on
and what um uh francis crick and jim
watson figured out
um was that one of the
shape that would be consistent with that
is the shape that uh is this double
helix shape that is the famous shape of
dna and i i think
i might be getting this history wrong
but i think the history was that rosin
franklin
had made the x-ray diffraction patterns
which were what were needed
to be able to figure out what shape it
was and then the mystery was well what
shape would it be and i don't know
whether
i think she didn't figure out what shape
it was whether she tried i don't know
and i think that the achievement of of
watson and crick
was to figure out what shape it was and
to figure out sort of the significance
of that shape
and the fact that with that shape you
could explain kind of genetic
information
in terms of uh of digital data
and uh and with this uh replication
thing in fact i think in that paper
they mostly concentrate oh it's a double
helix and i think there was a guy called
george gamoff who was a physicist
i think who had suggested the idea that
there might be sort of digital
information
that was used to encode genetics but
that's kind of how those things came
together so
so the you know it the the sort of the
cool picture of dna as a double helix
uh was one sort of thing the raw
material the raw data necessary to
figure out
even approximately what dna its shape
was came from a different place i think
from roslyn franklin
okay let's see um
let's see
gosh a lot of different questions here
well there's a question from mark here
um
how does one see colors when
actual color when when how do we see
colors what what does it mean what when
we say
it's pink it's uh
purple how do we tell that
okay that's actually reasonably easy to
explain
the he says that's always i should never
say that because that's always a setup
for realizing that
that it's hopelessly difficult um
what okay so light
consists of electromagnetic waves
which are uh kind of little tiny
amounts of electricity and magnetism and
uh because of the way the physics of
those things works
you can have little electric fields
little magnetic fields
and they travel at the speed of light
and that's what
an and and they they travel in such they
they go
so that the amounts of electric field
the amount of magnetic field
is varying actually a trillion times a
second in the case of light
roughly uh and um
and as as a as light propagates like the
light
that's going from you know from my face
to the camera here
it's moving through through space
and and there's a little tiny amount of
electric field tiny micromagnetic field
varying a trillion times a second and
that lump of
electricity and magnetism is traveling
at the speed of light
okay so the exact rate at which the
electric and magnetic fields vary
is what determines the color of the
light
with red light it varies slightly slower
than with blue light by a tiny factor
actually
and so that's the physical difference
between red light and blue light
is just how quickly those electro going
magnetic fields are varying
okay how do we perceive these things
well
light hits our eyes goes to the retina
which is the
collection of nerve cells at the back of
our eyes
and in those nerve cells there are these
things called cone cells which are a
particular type of nerve cell
we we humans normally if if we're not if
we
don't have color blindness um we we have
three kinds of cone cells um
and those three kinds of cone cells are
there
they're nerve cells and their special
nerve cells their nerve cells where
when a photon of light when a p when
some light
hits one of those nerve cells it causes
an electrical signal to be produced in
the nerve cell
and that electrical signal is
transmitted down our optic nerve to our
brain
and um the uh so the way it works is
we have three kinds of cone cells and we
have a kind of cone cell
kind of red cone cells which are most
sensitive
to light that has a frequency right
around uh the frequency of red light and
we have green
uh cone cells roughly it doesn't quite
work this way it's a little bit
subtle but but um roughly we have green
cone cells where we have um uh where
we're sensitive
uh to green light and blue cone cells
which are sensitive to blue light and so
what's happening is when we see
purple what's happening is that our our
red
that that piece of light is uh
has um uh has
um enough uh enough uh
that's in the enough sort of variation
that corresponds to the frequency of red
light
and enough that corresponds to the
frequency of blue light that electrical
signals are produced both in our red
cones and in our blue cones
and those electrical uh signals go to
our brain
and we've learned because we kind of
know
uh we've learned that when these
electrical signals
are when our brain has those electrical
signals that that's associated with it
with
uh with purple for example okay so
so that's that's basically how it works
and and what happens is
the the signal from our retina goes to
our primary visual cortex which is the
back of our head
um and uh uh the um uh
we we learn what different colors
correspond to now
again there is all kinds of subtlety in
this so what's actually transmitted in
the optic nerve and and the actual
um is actually differences red to green
uh uh is it blue to red i'm not sure
um but we actually we're actually
sensitive to the differences between
those colors
and you can actually test that there's a
there's a fun experiment
if you have a black and white disc and
um
you spin it at a certain rate um you
will
that black and white disc even though
it's just black and white um will look
like it has
bad it has rings of color on it and the
reason that you see rings
of color are because um
your the black and white light
uh you know the the white is just all
all
all frequencies of light so it's sort of
all colors black is
is no color no no light so you're
getting sort of bursts of light of all
colors coming
on your retina but it's happening let's
say i don't know
many times a second because this disc is
spinning around
um and what you're seeing is light no
light light no light
okay so it turns out that the time it
takes
your and i don't remember which one it
is but but let's say your red
cone cells to uh uh to kind of be ready
to receive the next signal is a bit
longer than the one for your blue cone
cells
and that's why instead of you just
seeing uniform gray
you see because you keep on seeing your
your red cone cells haven't
um haven't aren't ready to see a
different color you that that's why you
get the sort of mismatch between
the amount of of sort of red and blue
you see and it's because of this
difference
because the optic nerve only senses this
difference that you see these circles of
color
in what you would otherwise think it's
just a a um
a black and white disc rotating
um let's see
so ah gosh i have to go fairly soon here
unfortunately
um there's a piece of code here that
it's not easy for me to
immediately run and test out so i can't
can't do that but um
planumbra asks radio waves from the
planets when transformed into the audio
spectrum sound very strange
why do they sound so spooky well i
should i should get
i should pull up first question is which
which planets have lots of radio waves
jupiter
is the one with the most intense radio
waves
the sun also produces radio waves
um the planets that produce radio waves
are planets with magnetic fields so the
earth
um okay the earth is an example of a
planet with a magnetic field
and the earth's magnetic field um is
what allows you to use a compass
um the compass aligns itself with the
magnetic uh
magnetic field and the you know a bar
magnet
has a north pole and a south pole the
earth is a giant bar magnet
and its north pole is somewhere in
northern canada these days
um moves around a bit um and that
corresponds to that's
the the the earth is has a magnetic
field that's like the magnetic field of
a giant bar magnet
with the north pole of the magnet
roughly aligned with the north pole of
the earth
so how does the earth manage to have a
magnetic field it's because
of um electric currents that exist
in the molten core of the earth and it's
kind of
there are there's convection cells that
come because of heating and cooling in
the mantle of the earth and
people don't know exactly how this works
but roughly
it's through the sort of motion of of uh
this these electric currents are through
the motion of of
charged material in the in the liquid
core of the earth
and that produces this magnetic field
that we then
detect um on the surface of the earth
the reason that's relevant to radio
waves
is uh in space there's a thing called
the solar wind
which is a kind of a a bunch of
particles mostly electrons and protons
they're streaming outwards from the sun
in addition to producing light
the sun also produces the solar wind the
stream of particles that come outwards
from the sun
when that stream of particles uh
gets to the position of the earth um a
charged particle like an electron
uh will be diverted it will instead of
going in a straight line
it will be it will be um it will move
um as a result of the presence of the
magnetic field
and in in moving in that way it produces
radio waves and again if i had a bit
more time i'd probably explain
in more detail how that works um but
roughly there are electrons
um the uh um
well it's it's it's a little complicated
but but but basically when the electrons
are deflected by the earth's magnetic
field they produce radio waves
and so that's how radio waves are
produced uh
by um in um uh
uh so the ionosphere of the earth
has uh radio waves that it produces
um that you can you can hear with a
radio receiver
and they make kind of weird noises
um those noises are
in a certain range of frequencies and
again
uh well
the reason you're hearing those kinds of
sounds is because
there will be if if the ionosphere was
kind of um
fixed in structure there would just be
roughly a single frequency but it's
because of progressive changes
that you hear those changing slowly
changing frequencies
that sound like kind of spooky noises
now
okay jupiter okay so so the moon does
not have a magnetic field
why well that's pretty there's no molten
core on the moon
the moon is actually too small
presumably to have a molten core
the molten core of the earth is a result
of the fact that it still hasn't cooled
down since when the earth has formed
and it's also a result of radioactive
decay in the in the center of the earth
the moon has the moon is small enough
that it's kind of cooled down to be all
solid there might be a few little lumps
of liquid still left but it's probably
mostly solid
uh mars for example has a has a small
uh liquid core i think and has a i think
a tiny magnetic field
jupiter has a big magnetic field
and jupiter is a much weirder setup
because jupiter is mostly gas
i mean the the uh it's like the like um
it's kind of like a
in animals it's kind of like an owl
where there's a small little bird inside
and there's a big
fluffy thing of feathers outside but
jupiter's
atmosphere is very very thick um and
the actual core of jupiter which is very
weird it has it's under very high
pressure
it's probably solid hydrogen um and uh
it's
it's very jupiter is a very strange
strange thing if jupiter
was was not that much bigger than it is
it would have enough pressure inside it
that would actually
uh undergo nuclear fusion and it would
actually turn into a star
rather than a planet but jupiter
jupiter as it is has just a lot of
pressure in the center
and i'm not sure it is completely known
why jupiter has a large magnetic field
but i'm guessing
that the reason is that there are
essentially
uh streams of gas and liquid
that are circulating inside the the very
thick atmosphere of jupiter
and producing that magnetic field but i
don't i don't know that for sure
um but that magnetic field when it
interacts with the solar wind
um is what is producing the um
uh the the radio waves that you um
hear from jupiter at least i believe
that's correct
all right i think we should wrap it up
here um
and uh there were some questions here
about
um uh
oh yeah there's a comment here face
masks will be even more necessary in
space yeah that's a good question on the
on the international space station you
know what one of the big issues with um
uh one of the big uses of face masks
says if
you don't have a face mask when you uh
breathe out you are pushing
the air out at a certain speed and it
will go
many uh uh will go
many feet the droplets that you uh that
you push out which
if you're sick will contain virus will
go up many feet before falling to the
ground
now actually the problem is that when
the virus is in
is when it kind of dries out and you
don't anymore have a droplet of water
around it
um and even when you have usually we
produce sort of two
sizes of droplets of water usually when
we breathe out
and either when the thing is dried out
and doesn't have a droplet around it
or when it has one of the small droplets
those small droplets are so small
that little tiny currents of in the air
can keep it aloft
for a long time like hours um and so
you know if you don't have a ventilated
room where there's wind going through it
and so on
um then there can be droplets that are
just hanging out in the air
for a really long time and if you then
if somebody else then goes in there
they can breathe in those droplets now i
think what what's
what uh in the in in space um
even the larger droplets which would
normally fall to the ground
and that you sort of uh lose with with
sort of physical social distancing
um those those will not fall to the
ground in the iss so
so i guess some let's just hope that
none of the astronauts who go to the iss
that they've all been well tested
um and none of them are carrying uh uh
covet 19 because uh those viruses yes
it's quite completely true
social distancing won't work there
because the the uh the droplets will not
fall to the ground
um all right uh we better wrap up here
well nice to chat with you again today
and look forward to doing it again
uh hopefully next week hope you've
enjoyed this
uh this q a thanks a lot
and goodbye for now